-Performing
"Come Back as a Country Boy,"
from the deluxe edition
of his album, "Body Language,"
once again, Blake Shelton.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ When I die, I wanna come back
as a country boy ♪
♪ No, there ain't no better
life, if you ask me ♪
♪ If my neck
don't come out red ♪
♪ Then, Lord,
just keep me dead ♪
♪ 'Cause a country boy's
all that I know how to be ♪
♪♪
♪ My back is always breakin' ♪
♪ My dogs are always barkin' ♪
♪ My money has trouble makin' ♪
♪ And my truck has
trouble startin' ♪
♪ I'm up before the sun ♪
♪ Either haulin' hay
or huntin' ♪
♪ My work ain't ever done ♪
♪ But, son, I wouldn't
trade it for nothin' ♪
♪ So when I die, I wanna come
back as a country boy ♪
♪ No, there ain't no better
life, if you ask me ♪
♪ If my neck
don't come out red ♪
♪ Then, Lord,
just keep me dead ♪
♪ 'Cause a country boy is all
that I know how to be ♪
♪ Yeah,
if y'all ain't in my drawl ♪
♪ And a fish ain't on my wall ♪
♪ And the whiskey
don't burn going down ♪
♪ My feet ain't in a holler ♪
♪ And blue ain't on my collar ♪
♪ Leave my hand-cranking ♪
♪ Beer-drinking ass
in the ground ♪
♪♪
♪ When I die, I wanna come back
as a country boy ♪
♪ No, there ain't no better
life, if you ask me ♪
♪ If my neck
don't come out red ♪
♪ Then, Lord,
just keep me dead ♪
♪ 'Cause a country boy is all
that I know how to be ♪
Come on!
♪♪
♪ When I die, I wanna come back
as a country boy ♪
♪ Live off this land like
my old man did before me ♪
♪ I don't wanna be
born into money ♪
♪ Where the boots
don't ever get muddy ♪
♪ 'Cause a country boy's
all that I know how to be ♪
♪ When I die, I wanna come back
as a country boy ♪
♪ No, there ain't no better
life, if you ask me ♪
♪ If my neck
don't come out red ♪
♪ Then, Lord,
just keep me dead ♪
♪ 'Cause a country boy is all
that I know how to be ♪
♪ Yeah, a country boy
is all that I know how to be ♪
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]